in 2015 dr rodriguez while he pushed
things even further
performing the most extensive face
transplant
ever attempted patrick hardison was a
volunteer firefighter from mississippi
you were volunteer fireman greatest job
in the world well you don't get paid for
it sorry but
well you do what you love in 2001 he ran
into a burning building to rescue a
woman that was trapped inside
suddenly the burning roof collapsed
directly
onto patrick's head roof collapsed on
patrick
knocking down his helmet he felt the
mask on his face was melting
patrick held his breath he jumped out of
a window with his melting face mask
clinging to his face it claimed his
scalp his nose his lips his ears his
eyelids
and all of the skin on his face i
remember everything
from getting in the ambulance to the
helicopter
i don't remember much after that he was
burned so badly that his fellow
firefighters
they couldn't even tell who it was i had
no idea who i had
until we put him in the aimless and he
pulled me down over his face
and he said take care of chrissy and the
kids
that's when i knew who i had i mean it
was a
rotten damn day you had said in an
interview you'd do it again tomorrow
yeah and
i hate that i can't do it now this
burning roof
literally collapses on your head it
destroyed
your eyelids your lips your ears your
nose i could still
talk i mean i could still communicate
i could um i never thought it was as bad
as what it was even when my friends came
up there they would be all upset and i
was like man
just chill out i got this you know i
never thought it was that bad when you
looked in the mirror
what is that well i didn't actually see
myself until
probably november i got injured in
september probably november of that year
they had cut a little pinhole in one of
my outlets because they had everything
covered with skin grafts i looked in the
mirror and all i could do was i mean
i said this is it i can't do this it's
um
what do you mean you can't do this well
it's just i mean you have those thoughts
when i got kids it was just a tough time
i never got a day off from the injury
when you walk out in public it was
daily and it you know just so
there's no way to explain everything
this injury follows you wherever you are
right you never get a day off i mean it
doesn't matter you go to the ball
field you got to prepare yourself for
the kid that's going to run off
screaming
you know it's just like how painful is
that that's got to be painful
you never know and you're living with
this
for 14 years i went to my eye doctor and
he told me he said that
basically we've done all we can do he
said it's there's i can't rebuild
eyelids i can't make them blink right
and a good friend of mine had told me he
said well he was
driven me up to the doctor that day we
were headed home and he said i want to
look into the possibility of a sex
transplant
he got home and he googled space
transplant in the united states and it
showed up
dr uttering in baltimore when he had
done one earlier
and he emailed him and the next day they
called
and i mean it was just like this
guy's timing just everything is lined up
as it should
okay open your mouth for me okay just
relax and feel your lips here
even after 71 surgeries and skin grafts
from his legs
for 14 years patrick lived with what
doctors described as pinhole
vision a mass of scar tissue was all
that was left
his eyelids his lips ears nose
completely destroyed
we've been evaluating patrick in new
york at nyu
the goal is to replace the entire face
the ears
the scalp give him
get rid of all the portions of the face
that were burned in the fire
and make him look normal with dr
rodriguez
on board patrick finally had hope but
they still needed to find a donor
i've done a lot for her they're working
hard every day trying to get this
transplant done
so hopefully it's not much longer
get up every morning you think it's day
the day you know you
you know just the next day the same way
it's just
that's how it is so hopefully it'll
happen soon it's in god's hand so
it'll happen when he's ready for it to
happen i know he's got an angel out
there
for me somewhere and he's gonna call it
home one day and you know hopefully
when that day comes that family is
strong because i cannot imagine losing
somebody
at a young age and then having to be
asked to give what they're
asking to give now finally the call came
there was a match you have to tell them
this may not work you may not survive
this most people know that i'm a very
clear straightforward shooter and and i
tell them
this operation could kill you i hate to
use this phrase because it's so
silly and cliche but you're willing to
be the guinea pig
you're willing to risk your life but you
also knew that
this would advance medical science
i never had any doubts i mean from day
one i've told dr rodriguez whatever it
takes let's get it done
he's a gentleman who has five children
and i need him to understand
that this operation could kill you and
you can leave your children without
their father
was there any hesitancy no hesitation on
the morning of the operation with our
entire team ready to go
i asked him once again joe patrick are
you sure you want to do this i will call
off the whole thing right now i do not
want you to feel bad about this
on all instances no hesitation i need
this let's move forward
great attitude
what does that feel like for you
you're also in this game you're not in
medicine
to lose lives you're in medicine to save
lives
and that's a lot of a lot of pressure
what does that feel like there's no
question you know
everybody's got a lot to to lose in all
of this
and i feel ultimately responsible
something bad happens
of which things could happen that are
outer control
but there is that potential glory if we
can achieve this i think about the
number of individuals that we can
potentially help
finish the game
after 14 years of waiting that moment
had now arrived
dr rodriguez and his massive medical
team they were about to attempt
the most complex face transplant ever
performed in history
a procedure that would last more than 26
hours